oui
[Musique]
c'est nous le parti du des balles partie
des idées parti qui réfléchit qui
propose des havrais parti de
gouvernement et le deuxième axe c'est
vous c'est la jeunesse
il ya la nécessité de construire un
mouvement jeune et on doit le construire
en reflet de ce qu'est notre société
durant cette journée nous avons
rassemblé l'ensemble des responsables
départementaux jeunes des républicains
ici au siège la rue de vaugirard
notre volonté c'est de travailler à
rassembler la jeunesse de notre pays
autour de nos valeurs
ce matin était consacré à la définition
de ces valeurs qu est ce que la droite
quel espoir la droite peut porter pour
la jeunesse et nous débutons un chemin
de reconstruction d'un mouvement jeunes
qui a l'ambition de devenir le premier
de france dans les mois qui viennent le
travail est l'intérêt de la réunion de
ce matin c'était vraiment de réfléchir
sur un socle d'idées commun je pense que
ce qui nous rassemble c'est les valeurs
du mérite
saveurs l'autorité ce qui nous rassemble
aussi c'est l'amant de la france une
idée majeure force qui est celle de la
méritocratie républicaine celle de faire
en sorte que chaque enfant doit pouvoir
mieux vivre que ses parents grâce à son
travail grâce à ses études grâce à sa
volonté on voit bien qu'à une vraie
effervescence au niveau des jeunes
une vraie volonté d'avancer des idées
qui viennent de partout chacun des
parcours différents et on arrive tous à
se retrouver à discuter à échanger et
vraiment on a tous une vraie volonté de
reconquérir les territoires
ce matin on est l'occasion d'échanger
avec plusieurs personnalités politiques
du mouvement ça nous permet de nous
élancer de relancer la machine
notre responsabilité au niveau des
départements et votre responsabilité
nationale c'est d'ouvrir les portes et
les fenêtres et d'aller conquérir faire
adhérer donner envie en toi devenir le
premier parti j'ai senti les alternants
et lycéens et jeunes agriculteurs c'est
important de faire en sorte que la
jeunesse soit un des deux piliers sur
lesquels on va pouvoir refonder la
droite reconquérir le terrain des idées
pro conquérir le terrain tout simplement
faire en sorte que toute cette jeunesse
de 18 à 30 ans puisse avoir
du coup voix au chapitre on l'a bien vu
aux municipales que très peu jeunes ont
voté une cire seulement à se déplacer si
ce n'est moins sûr beaucoup de communes
on peut pas laisser ces jeunes de côté
leurs galères elle laissait spectateurs
donc de cette vie politique il faut lier
les rendre acteurs leur faire comprendre
les enjeux
ce qu'il faut c'est que les français
comprennent que ce que l'on plante c'est
un message une liste de messages qui
porte toujours des volumes et tout ça on
sait des débats ça ne peut pas se faire
sans ce jeune rendez vous à tous les
jeunes républicains mes amis rbj rdj à
mes amis délégués de circonscription
jeunes tous mes amis jeunes républicains
qui sont les vraies forces vives de
notre mouvement vous donne rendez-vous
dans les yvelines à port-marly les 4 et
5 septembre
je compte sur votre mobilisation
[Musique]
nous